[Música]
angelito Dávila murió envenenado tenía
dos años Jennifer y su familia lo están
velando en Bogotá antes de ser cremado
cada vez que uno de ellos se va se va a
una parte de tu corazón y debes
despedirlos con el respeto y el amor que
les diste en vida y como se merece como
parte de la familia este seguro de
exequias para mascotas se paga
mensualmente con los servicios públicos
capillas de la fe es pionera en ofrecer
la velación en Colombia quieren que las
familias puedan despedir a sus animales
igual que a los humanos para nosotros
las mascotas son son creaciones de Dios
que merecen respeto que merecen cuidado
que merecen amor y nosotros nos
preocupamos también por darles esa
última despedida y poder acompañar a sus
familias
Y de qué murió murió de eutanasia
compasiva Henry Cortés recoge el cadáver
de nube es el fundador de funerabet la
primera funeraria para mascotas de
Bogotá hacen unos 9000 Servicios al año
la competencia en el sector es fuerte
por lo que desde 2008 crearon un
cementerio el lote tiene un costo de 200
dólares por 5 años Allí va a ser
enterrada en v la familia ha pedido
respetar su dolor y no ser grabada por
favor que mi muerte no sea en vano que
sirva para que otro tenga la suerte de
poder vivir y conocer lo maravillosa que
es tu amistad Muchas gracias nube es
enterrada nosotros pusimos el aviso y
las personas nos fueron pidiendo a
medida que iban ofreciendo el servicio
ellos eran los que pedían un
recordatorio que pedían las cenizas o
pidieron un servicio de cementerio pero
yo no me inventado nada Eso lo único que
hice fue poner un emprendimiento Y
tratar de que esto surgiera en este país
en la muerte y en la vida la inversión
en los perros cada día es mayor en
Colombia
son las 6 de la mañana es jueves y Luna
tiene colegio vive con Óscar Ávila
profesor universitario escogió el
apartamento por las necesidades de
espacio de Luna Sí pues ella ya es parte
de la familia Yo yo la verdad yo soy de
Esta generación es que no piensa mucho
en tener hijos vaya
Bogotá tiene 3,5 millones de mascotas
más que la población de Uruguay la
capital de Colombia tiene cerca de 300
colegios caninos la mensualidad para
estudiar es de $120
Luna llega a cultura canina Una
institución educativa está en las
afueras de Bogotá
Juan Pablo Páez es el rector Esta es
nuestra primer clase del día es la clase
de aprendizaje de adiestramiento La idea
es que los perritos desarrollen
conductas relacionadas con la obediencia
básica como sentarse venir al llamado
muy bien tiene 40 trabajadores
propósito de este ejercicio es generar o
entrenar un concepto que se llama la
resiliencia la resiliencia es la
capacidad de afrontar los problemas y de
salir adelante por sí mismo muy bien
cada día reciben 150 perros
es una clase de de sensibilización y a
la vez contracondicionamiento frente a
los sonidos de la pólvora a través de un
enriquecimiento ambiental además de
colegio cultura canina ofrece servicios
de veterinaria peluquería
cumpleaños
feliz e incluso celebran los cumpleaños
de los perros los colegios caninos son
importantes porque brindan la felicidad
real a los perros que es la felicidad
real que ellos puedan venir a expresarse
como especie
los perros de Bogotá También tienen una
puerta de acceso a la atención
espiritual Julián Tenorio es comunicador
intereses esta sea a partir de la
intuición que la intuición es como la
puerta de entrada hacia nuestros
sentidos psíquicos esta terapia tiene un
coste de unos 70 dólares a mí me
gustaría saber qué piensan de mí
como como una persona muy amorosa a
partir de su conexión con el animal
resuelve preguntas de los dueños los
perros de Colombia también son
terapéuticos Entonces todos en Colombia
creo que tenemos familiares o fuimos
Víctimas de la violencia y siento Pues
que los perritos han sido ese apoyo
emocional ese ese reencuentro con la
vida con la esperanza
a unos 300 kilómetros de Bogotá esta
Pereira
la alcaldía de esta ciudad Tiene un plan
pionero de seguridad Social para
mascotas
Bruno es uno de los beneficiarios tiene
un año y fue atropellado su familia es
de bajos recursos y su operación
costeada por la alcaldía estaba valorada
en 260 dólares
un equipo de bienestar animal viene a
buscar a Bruno para revisar su pata en
el consultorio la patrulla ha atendido
alrededor de 10.000 mascotas en tres
años
parece que Bruno está mejor entonces
verlo recuperado ver que pudimos hacer
algo por él que esté bien es muy
gratificante para nosotros y para ellos
también
medidas como la seguridad social y otras
como la esterilización buscan combatir
el abandono de mascotas
muy cerca de Pereira y John Harold
castaño ejerce de profesor de Ecología
en la universidad rural de Santa Rosa de
cabal con las cámaras de movimiento
controlan las rutas de la fauna
Silvestre
Armadillos mapaches y guatines acá
tenemos la huellas de un perro se ven
cuatro dedos grandes con sus uñas y
encima de esa huella está la huella de
un guatín
después en su despacho John Harold
comprueba imágenes como estas
pero también sucesos como la muerte de
un jaguarundi por una manada de perros
abandonados
Este es el caldo de cultivo Para futuras
pandemias una ciudad con tan alta
diversidad y con perros y gatos
deambulando libremente en cercanía
directa con la fauna Silvestre
comiéndoselos o cazando puede ser un
escenario de transmisión de enfermedades
que aún no conozcamos
el primer gobierno de izquierda de la
historia de Colombia tiene animalistas
en la coalición
primero right primero right
Bueno después vamos con Micaela Micaela
y después la Nené para el senador de
izquierda Iván Cepeda sus perras han
sido un bálsamo durante su tratamiento
de quimioterapia ahora negocia con el
ejército de liberación nacional la
última guerrilla activa de América
Latina uno de los puntos del acuerdo de
paz contempla considerar por primera vez
víctimas a la naturaleza y los animales
en medio de un conflicto armado
evidentemente los animales sufren
también hacen parte de lo que le va
pasando a las comunidades donde
transcurre el conflicto
angelito vamos mi cielo la senadora
animalista Andrea Padilla va acompañada
de Angelito desde esta legislatura
senadores y representantes pueden llevar
a sus perros al congreso
porque implica entender que ellos
también son ciudadanos no humanos
ciudadanos de cuatro patas habitantes de
esta sociedad sobre los cuales se toman
decisiones por ejemplo de política
pública perros que van a la escuela
perros que son velados y perros con
acceso al congreso vida de perros los
nuevos hijos de Colombia